[Musique]
voir des enfants alors d'une ourse
nous voilà arrivés rue des enfants sages
et oui pas trop et tu ne descend pas
voir et charmant petit neveu givet et ce
soir ils vont voir ce qu'ils vont voir
hop je veux et voilà notre nounours rien
décidé je me demande ce qui va se passer
vous voyez là dedans il y a des sous
pour faire un joli cadeau à notre maman
oui à notre papa ou le bol sur lui pour
les eaux
bonsoir mes neveux tu vois nous on va
casser notre tirelire pour faire des
beaux cadeaux à papa et à maman pour le
1er janvier
c'est très gentil ils vont être bien
contents et qu'allez-vous bon le refus
des cigarettes du chocolat
oui et puis tu es pas tout et aussi des
fleurs pour maman est aussi une cravate
avec des pages au bout des six ports
sata
ils vont en avoir de beaux cadeaux à
l'eau rémi toto et fanfan
pendant que nicolas et pimprenelle
ouvrent leur tirelire
nous on va faire un peu de ménage allons
en avant vous avez fait les petits
cochons
aujourd'hui au travail au ballet le jeu
vous et allez y vous savez où ce soit
aux ménages d'entre voilà voilà
oula que tous ou
quelle fortune anneaux online a beaucoup
jean yanne axe on va les compter
ensemble
enfin jeter à l'eau ne touche pas aux
confitures 7 4 3 dix neuf 40000 non 900
mhz et wi mur
ça gonfle ses pinceaux donc tout un pan
jamais pourquoi de francs alors voyons
voir ce mail à m
j'ai eu des feux ont fait du bon travail
au dodo les enfants je vous accompagne
ouvelle déjà occupé le devant nous ça
fait rien de nounours on va se coucher
dans notre lit oui et qui sont chiants
tu peux partir des noces on va les
bercer au revoir tous maison fond jaune
un domaine où revenant ce adema mois ci
la fin de la journée c'est la maman de
ce projet nous faisons comme nos amis
il semble en tous sens
nous y allons aussi nous sommes bien
dans notre lit nov
houphouët avoir nui sa grosse voix m'a
fait plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir saf manouche et
plaisir ils sont vraiment adorables ce
soir tous nos petits amis
nuxe a pas trop nous sommes fous vous
aussi les petits enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents et allez
vite vous coucher sagement allons en
doute mon bon nounours bonne nuit fais
de beaux rêves de bord
[Musique]